JENNY BROWN: Today, we're
talking about a new Cloud
region, open-source security
protocol, and a Cloud Logging
update.
I'm Jenny Brown, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Digital tools like
cloud computing
are fueling economic
transformation across the US.
For example, Google's investment
in cities and communities
across Ohio is bringing
over 200 jobs to the state
and is helping provide
almost $13 billion
of economic activity for tens
of thousands of Ohio businesses.
And to accelerate
that transformation,
we are thrilled to announce
the newest Google Cloud region
in Columbus.
The Columbus Cloud region is
open and brings a second region
to the Midwest, the 10th
region in North America,
and grows our global
Cloud region count to 33.
We believe that PSP
can provide a number
of significant security
benefits for the industry.
Given its proven track record
in our production environment,
we hope that it can become a
standard for scalable, secure
communication across a
wide range of settings
and applications.
To support this, we are
making PSP open source
to encourage broader
adoption by the community.
Check out the blog
for more info.
We are thrilled to announce
the release of a new update
to the Cloud Logging
library for Node.js
with the key new features
of improved error handling
and writing structured logging
to standard output, which
is handy if you run applications
in serverless environments,
like Google Functions.
Head to the blog post for
a full list of details.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us,
and we'll see you in the Cloud.